has dropped by almost one third since
the end of the brexit transition period
that's according to data
seen by sky news and at the same time
costs have risen
as our business correspondent paul kelso
now reports
at a warehouse in wintery kent a spanish
lorry completes a 1 000
mile journey to meet our year-round
demand for summer produce
there's more room than normal inside
snow storms in spain have hit supplies
of some crops
and coved continues to cut demand well
we put a lot of soft fruit at this time
of year a lot of berries as well as
citrus coming in from spain
predominantly in january the main
challenge is the weather but there's
another issue that won't pass with the
seasons
new red tape at britain's borders is a
fresh challenge
even for companies like this with almost
70 years
trading experience we've had the added
challenge of brexit and the added
documentation that requires you know
hawley's have an extra cost in coming
here they don't know if their drivers
are going to get back
within a certain amount of time if they
look if the wheels aren't moving they're
losing money
and ultimately so are we freight ground
to halt in december when the french
border was closed by
covid but with routine testing now in
place companies still
face new customs checks and paperwork
adding cost
and complexity freight volumes have
slumped as a consequence lorry traffic
in both directions from eu states down
29 year on year and european hawleys are
less keen to come
the number of freight contracts from
france to the uk rejected
has risen 168 on last year
and that's put costs up moving
cross-channel freight now costs 47
more than in january 2020. brexit has
erected
barriers to trade between britain and
the eu where previously
there were none and just because you
can't see them and the traffic is moving
on these motorways in kent doesn't mean
they don't
exist one of the reasons it's quiet
is that many companies have stopped
importing and exporting
while they get used to the new rules
nims is one of them they're sourcing the
lemons for their air-dried fruit crisps
from egypt because of hold-ups in supply
from spain
and say the new regulations are slicing
already small margins
ever finer decided that for the month of
january we are not going to import
anything from the eu we're not going to
export to the eu
we were selling to five different
countries uh but we stopped exporting
pretty much
most of last year leading up to this for
foods containing animal products
it's even more complicated because our
product contains dairy
um every single export or order is now
going to require an export health
certificate which costs about
200 pounds and requires an official vet
to certify
the milk that we use is uh is okay so
that's going to add an extra 50 000
pounds a year annually to wild costs
officials say up to 200 lorries a day
are turned back at the border
fewer than they expected the result of
what ministers insist
are just teething trouble with the new
rules
that theory will face a sterner test if
and when traffic returns to normal
paul kelso sky news in kent